Michel seoget Chantal Hébert bonsoir à
vous trois bonsoir
bon
je disais hier
les journalistes qui depuis le tout
début suivent ça tous les jours ça prend
quand même une display mais aujourd'hui
tu as quand même fascinant d'écouter ça
un Premier ministre qui s'assoit qui
répond au pas à 3 mais à 8 avocats
Madeleine plantez nous le décor quand
même c'est exceptionnel dans politique
indienne ce chrétien est allé monsieur
rare depuis Paul Martin avec la
commission gomerée il y avait pas eu de
Premier ministre en exercice qui s'était
présenté comme ça devant une commission
d'enquête donc c'est exceptionnel c'est
aussi exceptionnel de voir un premier
ministre répondre à des questions
pendant 5 heures donc on voit souvent un
premier ministre participé à des
conférences de presse avoir le contrôle
pendant un certain moment faire des
mêlés de presse et on facilement
évacuer une mairie de presse lorsque ça
commence à pu faire notre affaire même
chose pour un point de presse une
commission d'enquête c'est pas possible
il devait rester sur la chaise avec les
pauses bien entendu mais restez sur la
chaise répondre aux questions et ne pas
donner l'impression de se défiler parce
que l'exercice bon il faut atteindre un
certain seuil pour respecter la loi ce
qui les convaincant ou non mais il doit
aussi faire l'exercice politique de
démontrer qu'il est en contrôle qu'il
est convaincant et qu'il ne se défile
pas et Patrice à mon avis il a coché
plusieurs cases aujourd'hui juste un cul
d'eau d'abord il y avait l'opinion
publique derrière lui et il y a rien
fait pour faire il y a pas fait de gaffe
là pour que le vent de l'opinion
publique change de bord on va on va y
revenir plus en détail mes premiers
tours de table sur le quand même le
caractère exceptionnel et effectivement
votre impression sur comment il a passé
ou non le test Michel
ça fait longtemps que je dis non j'en ai
vu du mauvais truc j'ai vu du bon truc
aujourd'hui d'autre part il y a quelque
chose d'assez exceptionnel c'est un côté
pédagogique de cette histoire là c'est
de voir comment le gouvernement fait
deal c'est prendre ses décisions dans
une situation de crise comme celle-là et
il y a pas assez beaucoup de temps à
expliquer j'ai parlé à mon conseil des
ministres après ça je suis allé voir ce
que la haute fonction publique me disait
de faire j'ai parlé au Premier ministre
français
privé qui est le premier fonctionnel
est-ce que vous me recommandez de faire
ça oui pour les vis non on va pas
souvent l'envers du décor comme ça ça
c'est intéressant et d'autre part
c'était une façon de suivre une autre de
dire j'ai été très rigoureux c'est pas
un coup de tête là je suis allé voir
tout le monde tout le monde me dit oui
il faut aller il faut aller là-dessus
parce qu'il y avait un style un danger
de violence et ça ça remplit le critère
de la loi alors je pense la raison il
avait depuis un public de son côté je
pense pas qu'il a fait grand chose
aujourd'hui pour le perdre mais c'était
quand même
un côté derrière le miroir alors qu'on
voit pas souvent et qui était assez
convaincre
Chantal c'est intéressant c'est vraiment
effectivement il a il nous a pris par la
main et qu'on le croit sur tous les
détails ou pas mais il nous a pris par
là il nous a mis dans chaque étape de
cette prise de décision qui reste
exceptionnelle le recours à cette loi
ouais soyons clairs c'est quand même la
procureur de la commission qui l'a pris
par la main et qui lui a fait expliquer
ses propres conversations parce que ce
qui était exceptionnel aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on avait accès en temps réel au
Premier ministre qui expliquait ce qu'il
avait dit dans des conversations privées
avec la gouverneur général avec le
premier ministre de l'Ontario alors il y
avait une ligne assez fine sur laquelle
Justin Trudeau devait se tenir et ne pas
franchir parce que il y aurait été
démenti par ses propres paroles
d'autre part bon on s'entend pas le
Martin Trudeau il y a eu un seul premier
ministre on imagine pas nécessairement
Steven Harper se prêter facilement un
champ de d'exercice là mais c'est
complètement différent de la compétition
de Paul Martin à l'époque parce que pas
le Martin parlait des commandites et
c'est pas lui qui était aux commandes au
moment de cette histoire-là tandis que
Justin Trudeau a pris la décision je
suis d'accord avec mes collègues et
aujourd'hui il y a pas perdu de points
dans l'opinion publique si vous pensiez
que je distingue avait raison
probablement qui vous a pas donné de
raison et ces ministres non plus cette
semaine de changer l'idée est-ce qu'il a
fait la démonstration de ce qu'il a
passé le test juridique de l'utilisation
de la loi ça c'est une autre question
quel juge rouleau va départager avec des
connaissances que moi j'ai pas bon c'est
intéressant on va écouter un pot pourri
d'extrait je pense il est essentiel on
revient parce que là on va aller le plus
en détail après sur parce que beaucoup
d'avocats lui disaient oui oui très bien
mais il y avait une peut-être un
apaisement à l'horizon lui dit non
est-ce que est-ce que c'est absolument
nécessaire bref mon écoute d'abord
à ce moment-là ça commence à être pas
mal clair que la situation allait
était si urgentes avaient un une
préoccupation que ça pourrait se
s'empirer dégringoler encore plus
ailleurs qui avait une urgence d'agir et
que
l'outil qu'on avait pour amener
rapidement
ces outils spécifiques c'était la Loi
sur les mesures d'urgence
ça a été plusieurs heures mais
l'essentiel de son argumentaire il a
donné des exemples il y avait des
enfants si on était pas sûr qu'il y
avait des armes des enfants c'est un
policier aurait pu être tué Michel soget
retour de table là-dessus
évidemment c'est difficile de prouver
qu'est-ce qui serait arrivé c'est pas eu
de loi là parce qu'on le sait pas c'est
pathétique par définition mais lui a dit
écoutez là moi il y avait un risque de
d'escalade il y avait un risque réel de
Scala a-t-il été convaincant là-dessus
la question c'est son jugement à lui son
jugement lui c'est la situation est en
train d'empirer il était pas en train de
s'améliorer il s'est fait suggérer par
des questions écoutez il y avait un
académie tel endroit tel endroit elle
dit oui mais dans en général on ne
croyait pas que la situation allait
mieux alors
[Musique]
et ça c'est pour ça qu'il payait pour
faire ces jugements là avec la fonction
publique avec les autres manuscrits bien
sûr alors
on pourra toujours dire il y a pas fait
la bonne décision il y a pas fait le bon
calme mais à la fin c'est lui qui prend
cette décision là et il logiciel comme
une comme une pensée qu'il a justifiait
Madeleine sur cette question là a-t-il
avec
selon vous avec assez de détails
expliquer pourquoi il est arrivé à la à
la conclusion qu'il fallait agir
maintenant qu'il y avait des mélanger
que ça ne se règle pas que ça s'empire
effectivement il y a parlé de toutes
sortes de dangers potentiels quand il
parlait par exemple d'enfants qui sont
qui servent de boucliers humains de
camions qui peuvent servir d'arbre tout
ça il l'a évoqué ça c'est jamais
finalement avéré et d'une certaine façon
c'est la faiblesse de l'argumentaire de
Justin Trudeau mais en même temps c'est
sa force d'une autre façon si on le
prend d'un autre point de vue c'est
moins grave je pense pour Justin Trudeau
de défendre une loi avec des menaces qui
sont dures à à saisir à capter que de
défendre une situation qui aurait
dégénéré une situation où il y aurait eu
des morts des blessés ça ça n'est pas
arrivé lorsqu'il est ce qu'il a dit
aujourd'hui Justin Trudeau c'est voyez
ça a fonctionné la loi a été mise en
place et on a réglé la situation et des
mois plus tard on n'a pas connu encore
une fois un convoi de la sorte qui est
venu
complètement paralysé une partie de
notre économie et de nos quartiers vous
disiez tout à l'heure
Michel mais les trois que ce qui était
rare c'est qu'on avait accès à une prise
de décision Chantal le fait que Monsieur
Trudeau explique il y a eu beaucoup
beaucoup de gens dans le processus qui
sont tombés d'accord bon lui
ultimement devait prendre la décision
mais il parle de conscience puis les
hauts fonctionnaires puis les mines etc
est-ce que ça ça ne l'aide pas en disant
tu es pas tout seul à forcer pour ça là
évidemment bon il y a deux choses qui
l'aident la première c'est le patron du
acrs lundi qui a dit je pense pas que ça
correspondait à la définition de la loi
sur la menace à la sécurité nationale
qui fait qu'on intervient mais j'ai dit
au Premier ministre s'en servir et ça ça
fait quand même une différence que le
cabinet aujourd'hui est fait consensus
on comprend que de toute façon
intérêt à avoir fait consensus c'est pas
le temps d'aller dire ouais moi j'avais
des réserves j'étais pas sûr que
j'aimais ça j'ai pas bien dormi
ça c'est la première chose l'autre chose
c'est le spectacle que les forces
policières ont donné à cette commission
au début des audiences c'est à dire très
désordonnées pas vraiment de plan de
match c'est beaucoup plus facile
aujourd'hui de croire que le plan qu'on
dit qui était là puis que Monsieur
Trudeau a court-circuiter avec la loi
des mesures d'urgence c'était pas un
vrai plan après avoir entendu tous ces
gens-là qui avant de les avoir entendu
alors je dirais qu'il arrivait dans un
bon contexte et qu'il en a tiré le
maximum intéressant en passant quand il
explique et on s'en doutait un peu là
que la loi des mesures d'urgence était
dans l'air depuis le début de la
pandémie rappelez-vous on en a parlé à
des panels que plusieurs disaient il
faut que Justin Trudeau prenne des
commandes en utilisant cette loi c'était
utile pour lui de le dire pourquoi parce
que à l'époque malgré toutes ces
pressions là qui étaient fortes qui
venaient
d'autres parties aussi il y a dit non je
ferais pas ça donc le message c'est je
suis pas le gars à qui vous donner un
revolver puis qui tire dans toutes les
directions
il a évidemment consulté les premiers
ministres des provinces voici un extrait
où il raconte derrière il a changé en
français notamment il allait parler de
monsieur Legault voici un extrait où il
dit j'ai voulu les rassurer dans les
policiers de la GRC arrivent en pas au
Québec partout si la SQ on le vu dans la
ville de Québec d'ailleurs en fin de
semaine les Cu a pu se débrouiller très
bien seul on écoute
par exemple le Premier ministre logo a
exprimé une préoccupation que
il voulait pas que tout à coup la GRC
vienne prendre contrôle de toutes les
tous les actions policières au Québec
quand il trouvait qu'il y en avait pas
besoin puis j'ai pu le rassurer et c'est
d'ailleurs quelque chose que j'ai
intégré dans dans mes
discours et communication par la suite
que
c'était là pour être utilisé si
nécessaire
c'est une exigence le Premier ministre a
consulter les provinces le jour même de
l'invocation de la loi et plusieurs
provinces sont allés dire c'est pas
vraiment de la consultation où nous avez
informé d'une décision qui était déjà
prise encore une fois le juge rouleau
pour un déterminer si c'était le cas ou
pas mais encore une fois est-ce que ça
va changer fondamentalement l'opinion
publique par rapport à tout ça j'en
doute bon le juge oui
j'entends
c'est le premier ministre l'Ontario la
Ville d'Ottawa jusqu'à preuve du
contraire est encore dans cette promesse
là le pont ambassadeur aussi et il y a
pas dit non il y a même dit oui oui
c'est exactement il y a même dit oui
c'est le seul qui a dit oui ben lui
était pris avec ça Ford s'appelait puis
quand vous disiez du Chantal tout à
l'heure
la performance des policiers le chef de
Brice d'Ottawa qui était désorganisé qui
lui-même est au désespoir quand il
raconte ça encore un an après alors ça
ça aide à crédité la thèse que Monsieur
Trudeau personne lui avait donné un vrai
plan mais le plan on peut pas le lire en
passant parce que dit j'aimerais ça que
vous lisiez puis caviarez
ça dans les longues papiers
pendant les jours qui ont précédé la
vocation de la loi des gens se
demandaient où est dogford est-ce que
Ottawa fait partie longtemps où est-ce
qu'il est le premier ministre bien sûr
qu'elle dit oui c'est sûr il y en a un
qui a dit moi je ne ferai pas c'est
scotchisme
si vous voulez le faire aux objectifs
alors c'est proche de l'unanimité qu'on
pourrait avoir conclusion on attend donc
ce rapport extrêmement important du juge
Roulot c'est la première fois c'est un
contrepoids qui est intégré dans la loi
qu'est-ce que vous attendez parce que
les gens ne veulent pas non plus que ça
facilite l'utilisation d'une loi comme
ça
tout le temps de rappeler du Chantal
je vous ai déjà parlé je pense de mon
inquiétude sur la pente savonneuse sur
laquelle la ministre des Finances aura
peut-être engagé du gouvernement hier ou
avant hier en disant
une menace économique c'est une menace à
la sécurité nationale à partir de ce
moment-là ça devient un passe-partout
ce matin un rapport en demi-teinte avec
une recommandation dans un ou une
conclusion dans un sens ou dans l'autre
mais je m'attends ce qui est beaucoup de
contextes et que ce soit peut-être long
à lire on aura de le lire un Madeleine
absolument mais moi justement est-ce
qu'on va voir une définition revue et
corrigée de l'état d'urgence de
situation d'urgence est-ce que ça va
être circonscrit est-ce que ça va être
élargi comme laisser entendre Christophe
Freeland mais moi je ne vois aucun
appétit la part d'un gouvernement
minoritaire d'aller changer cette loi là
dans les prochains mois donc même si le
juge rouleau le recommandait n'oubliez
minoritaire
la chose aussi à surveiller c'est la
procédure est-ce que la procédure qui a
été utilisée entre autres pour consulter
province entre autres dans la fonction
publique et la mode est-ce qu'il y a pas
des améliorations à avoir à la procédure
je pense que le juge rouleau va se
prononcer là-dessus aussi
on va il va aller réfléchir et tout ça
on a bien cette journée pour ceux qui
aiment la politique c'est une journée
quand même faut le dire fascinant
n'est-ce pas
une commission avec tous ces textos
qu'on a lu
ok merci j'ai plus de niaiseries je vous
laisse au revoir bonne fête salut bonne
fin de semaine pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici
RDI